a federal judge says the government
needs to quickly comply with a court
order to reunite young immigrant
children with their parents only 38 of
102 children under the age of five where
you were unified yet by yesterday's
deadline officials said last week that
nearly 3,000 children in all remain in
US custody everyone is supposed to be
reunited with their parents by July 26
media video is in El Paso Texas where
many families remain in limbo
nidia good morning well good morning
here in El Paso along the Mexico border
three fathers are waking up whole again
they were reunited with their children
late last night but a number of families
are still separated the government says
the holdup has to do with waiting on DNA
test results as well as criminal
background checks and they claim that
some parents are choosing not to be
reunified with their children on Tuesday
ever raise Mejia saw his three year old
son for the first time in three months
separated at the border the two were
reunited yesterday following a
court-ordered deadline the judges made
it clear he does not intend to be
hands-off at a federal court hearing
judge Dana Sabra told the government
they need to streamline the process of
family reunifications late in the day
Ruben Garcia with the annunciation house
shelter in El Paso got a call he was
waiting for all day do you believe that
they dropped him off this late at night
to meet that deadline that they promised
the federal court oh I'm sure I'm sure I
do believe that this was an effort to
comply with the court order of July 10th
and Trump responded to questions about
his administration's inability to meet
the deadline tell people not to come to
our country illegally yesterday we spoke
with Jocelyn who asks that we not use
her last name last month she was
reunited with her 15 year old son James
after nearly nine months of separation
do you believe that the government is
telling the truth when they say that
they can reunify these families well no
como do I have hope she said but that's
not a lot of time to reunify
Jocelyn and James are going to be
staying in a local shelter until their
immigration case is actually finished up
we understand right now judge Sabra has
said he will make sure to hold regular
hearings on this case so that he
continues to know that these
reunifications are happening fast in
fact his next status hearing is on
Friday Nora
all right Maria thank you that judge is
on it